the fact that people aren't on their
knees in gratitude all the time for the
fact that we have central heating and
air conditioning and pure water and
reliable food it's just it's it is
absolutely unbelievable used to die for
then the water supply they would admit
was contaminated with cholera for Evans
sakes a people can understand okay thank
had clean water and fresh milk fresh
orange juice all of these things there's
a mom at all of the time all the time
and that's in Western culture is heading
okay because because we are so dependent
on this on this invisible infrastructure
we're heading for an absolute
catastrophe when jihadists figure out
how to paralyze the power grid the
entire culture will be be chaotic you'll
have mobs in the street okay you know
within three days okay women so suddenly
the food supply is interrupted and
there's no like there's no way to
communicate they'll be like what the
robber I mean that is the way Western
culture is going to collapse
okay it won't take much just single
point so silly because we are so
interconnected now we are so it's so
it's so dependent on communications and
computers they eat it I used to preach
for years it'll be an asteroid hitting
there yeah I know how the solar flares
work so back in this happens about once
every century so back about 1880 and I
don't remember the exact year there was
a significant enough solar flare so that
produces an electromagnetic pulse like a
hydrogen bomb because the Sun is a
hydrogen bomb an electromagnetic pulse
will emerge from the Sun and wave across
the earth and it produces huge spikes in
electrical electrical current along
anything that's electronic and it'll
burn them out it let it live telegraph
operators on fire in the 1800s and Wow
one of those things took out the Quebec
power grid in 1985 and knocked out the
whole Northeast Corridor and so they
figure those things are about 1 in a
century event but those single while you
have my brother-in-law who's a very
smart guy he designed the chip an iPhone
we were talking about political issues
the last time I went and saw him in San
Francisco and his notion was that all
that the government should be doing
right now is stress testing our
infrastructure the same way they stress
test the banks because we're so full of
these single points of failure that and
I think you're absolutely right luckily
we've
what would you call invaded by stupid
terrorists instead of smart terrorists
because a smart terrorist could do an
unbelievable amount of damage in a very
short period of time so and it's just
God's good graces that that hasn't
happened yet and so what will happen is
that it's the men ok the men will
reconstruct civilization while the women
cower in the houses and they have the
men go out and do all the dirty work
that's what's going to happen again only
men will bring civilization back again